you're always wondering when it's gonna
come to life he's here unlawfully you've
got recall Susan wanted them to be hurt
he's trying to short-circuit the process
and jump in the front of the line it's
terrible it's really not a good way
today
ever since I was ten years old my dream
has been to become an attorney here I'm
at 35 and that has not changed
sergio garcia is a mild mannered
approachable guy he grew up and still
lives in the small town of durham
california where people know him by name
his mother and father even worked as
farmworkers in the area
in 2009 he passed the California State
Bar and if you ask him it was a very big
moment in his life
22 years later I would had finally
achieved my dream it felt great you know
was the best day of my life
but then things got complicated the last
group of people that needed to sign off
on his license the California Supreme
Court stopped short saying that they
needed to review the case a bit more
what tripped them up well there's one
more thing you should know about Garcia
he doesn't have documentation to live in
the United States you're always
wondering when it's gonna come to light
like anything else that anything else
that is personal you don't go out there
and meet people in town I'm Sergio
Garcia by the way I'm undocumented but
Garcia wanted to tell the truth on his
application for a license the detail
prompted the California Supreme Court to
ask the US Justice Department of
granting Garcia a license would violate
immigration law Justice Department said
it would on the grounds that an unlawful
alien doesn't have the right to work in
the United States the notion that we can
give a license to practice law to
somebody who cannot lawfully practice
law under federal law is a bit bizarre
John Eastman is the former dean of
Chapman Law School and doesn't think
Arcia should receive a license the law
is very clear it says that states cannot
provide benefits to people who are
illegally in the country and it defines
benefits to include professional
licenses but Garcia's story gets even
more complicated you see he didn't
choose to come to the US on his own
initially he had 70 months old my
parents brought me I really can't tell
you exactly how that went
I was here the first nine years of my
life in at that point
in 86 that's when I
back to Mexico then he returned to
Durham California when he was 17 to
finish high school it was only then that
his father told him about his status had
helped him apply for a visa since then
he's been waiting for that visa to come
in the mail and now he's waiting for the
state supreme court to decide what it's
going to do listen to federal law or
chart its own course it's a decision
that Eastman says has already been
decided because under our Constitution
the power over immigration policy is
vested with Congress that federal law
prevails over anything the state might
want to do for Eastman the answer is
clear he's here unlawfully he's not gone
back to his home country and sought to
apply like everybody else had waited in
line in the home country who's trying to
short-circuit the process and jump in
the front of the line I think if
immigration law history we're different
from what it is that might be a
reasonable view
Hiroshi modem aura is a law professor at
UCLA and the author of the book
Americans in Waiting The Lost story of
immigration and citizenship in the
United States Sergio Garcia's case is a
very complicated one there a lot of
factors going each way but in the end I
would say that Sergio Garcia should be
allowed to practice law motomeru says
that when you look at the details Garcia
is qualified to be in the u.s. he just
doesn't have the documentation that says
so his status has a certain ambiguity to
it and the reason is that he is
qualified to get permanent resident
status in this country he's qualified
for what they call a green card which
means that you can stay in the country
indefinitely and you're eligible for
citizenship after five years and his
qualifications go beyond being eligible
for a visa he has the approval of the
State Bar Board of Examiners he passed
there positive moral character
evaluation and he's never committed a
crime he sounds like a wonderful
individual the kind of person many
communities in Mexico might like to have
to bolster their local economy Eastman
says that the State Bar's approval of
Garcia's license comes down to politics
the California bars decision to support
giving a law license to Sergio Garcia I
think is more agenda driven or politics
driven
than law driven I think if they were to
look more carefully at the laws that are
on the books that have actually been
passed by Congress they would see that
what they're doing is illegal
Moda mara agrees at least in part
there's a law that says it's violation
of federal law to hire someone who
doesn't have permission to work someone
who hires him would be breaking a law if
they hired him as an employee what's not
clear though is whether he can hang out
a shingle and practice as a lawyer
because there's an exception of that law
that says you can be an independent
contractor so if you hire someone in a
loose sense of the word hire they're not
your employee you hire them to handle
the case or something like that and
that's not necessarily violation of law
if you're confused you're not the only
one American immigration law is a maze
of red tape and since the turn of the
century it's been selectively enforced
we've had a history in this country we
have an immigration law that keeps a lot
of people out but ever since the early
20th century the enforcement has been
selective enforcement had been
discretionary
for instance take Garcia being deported
given my status is a possibility but
it's highly unlikely they would have
already come and picked me up they know
where I live they know my name they know
all my vital information all that
information is provided to them at the
time of applying to adjuster status they
know exactly where I am and that just
tells me that they feel that I'm a
person that does not need to be removed
from this country Eastman says that when
you don't remove people you pay for it
in other ways namely in Social Welfare
benefits to draw on immigration to get
access to those social welfare benefits
is huge and when you look at the costs
the costs in public education that the
Supreme Court is required to be provided
the costs and emergency health care and
compare that to the benefits that they
may provide I think the states that are
saying you know this is costing us a lot
more than we're getting or probably
right the federal government brings in a
lot of revenue
from people who are working in the
country without papers they pull it in
through social security they pull it in
through income taxes undocumented
workers are remarkably law-abiding with
regard to paying taxes
well the Social Security Administration
doesn't keep track of undocumented
immigrants they do keep track of w-2
federal tax forms that don't match up
with real names or numbers in their
system they call it their earnings
suspense file
the suspense file says the
administration collected twenty-eight
point six billion dollars from 2008 to
2010 and uncredited taxes we've allowed
tolerated I think acquiesced and having
1112 million people in the country
outside the law that's been the
situation for the least the last couple
of generations since the mid-1960s and
the reason for that is we have an
economic system that relies on
undocumented labor even though people
are in the country unlawfully the system
the economy and government policies and
wanted them to be here so in that
situation it's not so simple to say well
if you're in the country illegally then
we can basically treat you as badly as
we want that's the reason why the
Supreme Court decided 1982 that
undocumented kids have the right to go
to school that's the reason why courts
in many situations recognize that people
even though they're here unlawfully have
rights rights in the workplace rights to
fire protection rights to marry rights
to certain public benefits we don't take
too kindly to people to cut in line at
the movie theater I'm not sure why we
should do it in people that cut in line
in order to get in for in the front
access to the United States and all of
the wonderful benefits we provide
motomeru says the immigration line isn't
like a movie theater line though where
everyone just waits their turn to get a
ticket there's no real line for a lot of
people to stand in or the line that
they're made the standing is much longer
because of the country they're from
Garcia is on a very long wait list right
now and that's another interesting thing
because he's on a wait list he's been
qualified the difficulty is that he's
from Mexico and you have to wait longer
if you're from Mexico which is another
thing about the system it's not often
understood it's true according to State
Department figures for the last year the
waiting list for Mexicans came in at
almost 1.4 million more than any other
country so if the immigration line is a
line at all it's more like a line where
everyone stay
side by side each immigrant has a
different status a different situation a
different story but each is hoping that
someone else will make their dream come
true independently of my status I have
to fulfill my dreams I have to believe
that all that work I have put into it
it's not gonna be in vain the knowledge
you learn everything you gain up here is
not dependent on a piece of paper it's
something you learn in something that
will stick with you and help you
throughout your life
you